は）ただいまっくすむらい！
ば）ママ入れる程度にして
ぶーっとさめているとだめっちゃ
は）わかった、とめてくる
移動してくる
ばあちゃん、そりゃ、しんどいわ
というわけで、はじめしゃちょー実家に帰ってきておりま～す
あの、年末もお正月もちょっとバタバタしてて
実家に帰れなかったんですけども
ちょっとUFESも終わって、ヒマではないです
ヒマではないですけど、ようやく実家で、ゆっくりできそうなので
帰ってきましたというわけで
車を変なところに駐車するなと、ばあや に怒られてしまいました
まずは、車の移動からだ
やっぱね、誰かと一緒に暮らすとは、そういう事ですよ
一人暮らしに慣れてしまって
集団の生活というものができなくなってしまっているので
がんばってね、ちょっとずつ、家族のいる生活に慣れていければいいなと思います
富山にいるのは、そんな長くはいないですよ
ば）だめやっちゃぁ～
え、どういうこと？向きを変えろっていう事？
オーケー、オーケー、ノープロブレム、向きを変えてくるわ
は）名言頂きましたね
は）うまい？上手い？
は）もう、いいっしょ？　信じるよ？ばあちゃん、信じるね
ば）え？
は）信じるね
ば）大丈夫
は）はい
ば）お母さんの、そのシャッターのとこまで、ゆっくり、オーライ、オーライ
は）怖いよー
ば）オーライ、オーライ、まだ大丈夫
は）ばあや・・・
は）あ！ああぁぁあ！
は）オーケイ
では、2階に行ってきます
は）撮ってもいい？
じ）どうぞどうぞ
はい、という事で実家に帰ってきました
年末、お正月も、ちょっとバタバタして実家に帰れなかったんですけども
まあ、ちょっとイベントなども 一段落して、ようやくちょっと家でゆっくりできそうでございます、と言いつつも
こっそり、動画を撮っているという
実家だと、ゆっくりしたいので、さすがにちょっと軽い動画になると思います
毎日、出せるかわかんないんですけども、極力出していこうと思います
なんか、なんか、いいのないかな
せっかく、実家にきたのに、何かこう…見ていきたいよね
中学校の時のバスケ部の写真
髪の毛、短いなぁ
はい、こんな感じです。ちょっと身長大きめだな
そんなに長くいるつもりはないですけど
一週間以内ぐらいかな
では、実家でちょっとゆっくりします
じゃあな
ば）まさか映っとるんじゃなかろうね
は）大丈夫です、声だけの出演です
ありがとう
ありがとう、ばあちゃん ありがとう
これで僕は、生きることができるよ